Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie
So today we're going to talk about
Game of Thrones characters that just do not give a crap
about the Iron Throne anymore.
Chief among them,
dragons. Obviously dragons absolutely do not care for the Iron Throne.
Not that they ever did.
Just, careful for spoilers through season 4
we don't necessarily have to get in to book stuff, so
if you only watch the show, you should be just fine.
If you want to add anybody to the list,
feel free. This is only going to be a top 5
So there's no way everyone's going to make the list.
So here we go, starting with number 5:
Bronn
This is almost a cheat,
because he's like the king of not caring about almost anything.
I think maybe having sex,
like, that's probably what he cares about most.
Having sex,
and filling his pocket with someone else's gold.
It seems like he's been Tyrion's best friend,
but really, I think he's only been his best friend as long as
Tyrion has supported his request for more gold.
Bronn's like an afternoon delight,
love the one you're with kinda person.
I don't think he's obsessed with money.
Yes, he's a mercenary,
he works for whoever pays him,
but he's not a slave to the acquisition of wealth
that the Lannisters are.
I think a really good example of his character is
the last time he saw Tyrion in The Black Cells.
His friend was getting ready to get his head chopped off,
and it just seemed like he almost didn't care about anything.
He was kind of sad to see him go,
but he was like, "well, what're you going to do?"
Now that Bronn is a lord though
I'm interested to see how it changes his behavior
in season 5.
The show has actually turned him into a main character,
like if you look at the season 5
cast list, he's actually a main character.
In the books, not so much.
Moving on to number 4 though:
Sansa Stark
This is a pretty easy one, I think she just mostly cares about staying alive
Little Finger seems like he has this very creepy, grand plan for her.
She kind of started to pick up on it at the end of season 4,
like she dyed her hair, they're obviously going to go on the run.
But I don't think she really cares about
who sits on the Iron Throne,
least of all, herself.
You'd think that the surviving Starks
would care most about finding the rest of their family.
Of all them, Sansa's kind of been the slowest to get her ass in gear.
That's why in season 5 I'm really excited to see if she does anything crazy!
Like if she comes to the breaking point, like if Arya
and Jon Snow are starting to go through big character transformations,
maybe Sansa's going to as well.
There's this thing called narrative proximity
that George R. R. Martin is a big fan of,
where big things happen to similar characters.